my goal is to pass this [ __ ] to my  daughter to be honest with you i tease  her all the time you're about to be a  little ceo you better learn the game and  she already has a clothing line yeah  that's why i did that  she understands  that's big and i never you notice i  don't really promote her [ __ ] like that  because i'm making her and her make her  figure out you got to figure it out  how's it doing it does cool it could do  a lot better but and i'm sure if i post  it every day and every drop i'd probably  do way better but i want her to learn  the struggles i don't want to just give  her everything she's got to work for it  but like me and her bond by like designs  and like  we could flip a jacket like this or you  could do like this or you can and she's  really proud of her [ __ ] and she wears  it to school and  i couldn't be more proud of her but i  wanted to learn that [ __ ] hands-on you  know